[Music]
thank you
this is the fossilized egg of a giant
dinosaur a titanosaur
when freshly laid it would have weighed
around a kilo and a half and its shell
is about two millimeters thick
while the eggs certainly were tough
they still needed to be kept safe and
warm
so how did dinosaurs take care of their
eggs
in order to protect their eggs from
predators and to keep their eggs warm
dinosaurs evolved a list of strategies
one of these strategies was to build a
nest and then to actually sit on top of
the nest
we know certain dinosaurs did this
because we actually have fossils of
dinosaurs sat on top of nests
eggs found in these nests contain tiny
babies of the same species as the adults
providing the first evidence that some
dinosaurs looked after their young
but although this offered protection and
Shelter From The Elements there was a
downside to incubating eggs in this way
having to sit on an egg and actually
look after it means that you are
committed to the care of that egg for
the entire duration of their development
up until the point of hatching
for some dinosaurs it was a commitment
worth making
[Music]
but others like sort of parts
faced a different challenge
it's likely that some dinosaurs never
sat on their eggs after all many of
these animals weighed tons and tons and
would simply have crushed them before
they had any chance of hatching
Jim what was their solution
there are some support egg clutches
where the female excavated a long trench
with her back feet
she then back filled the trench once she
had laid all the eggs
this Behavior can be seen today
Turtles bury their eggs to protect them
from predators
and this unwarmed sand keeps them at the
ideal temperature
but some dinosaurs had another trick to
keep their eggs warm
[Music]
we think some dinosaur groups
deliberately collected and piled up
rotting vegetation
they basically formed a compost heap on
top of their egg-filled nests
in Australia use this remarkable
technique
as the vegetation breaks down it
releases enough heat to incubate their
eggs for around seven weeks
it was a discovery in 2010
that revealed that some dinosaurs had an
even more unusual way of keeping their
eggs warm
they use heat from the Earth itself
in one particular site in Argentina
that's had lots of sauropod egg
discoveries it's right next door to some
geothermal Springs
we're thinking the sauropods were using
that volcanic activity to help keep its
eggs warm
another location the Deccan region of
India one of the most volcanic areas
during the late Cretaceous provides more
evidence
there are many many layers of lava then
in between the lava flows we find
dinosaur eggs
[Music]
dinosaurs were coming to this location
even when it was highly active
volcanically using it as a nesting site
for literally centuries
[Music]
dinosaurs had many ways to ensure their
eggs would hatch
certain of one thing
their methods worked very effectively
helping them to rule the world for over
150 million years
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]